let's make way for Paul Finebaum the
popular New York Times bestselling
author ESPN commentator and you can
listen to him on ESPN radio every single
day Monday through Friday
right here was the guest Paul we were
wondering your favorite artist or band
growing up now save your answer I'm
gonna go you're from Memphis Tennessee
I'm gonna go Elvis Presley was your
favorite artist growing up holy you got
one I'm I was that's a great guest Dan
I'm gonna go close to that I'm gonna go
Johnny Cash Johnny Cash all right it's
bring in Paul Finebaum Paul your
favorite artist yeah into college my
favorite artist was Neil Young okay
right that's good
I mean me he was so depressing and it
just it's it my mood all right that's
all we wanted to hear from you poker so
I'm wondering if we're gonna see
conferences come back and play you know
could the SEC go rogue in a situation
like this with college football coming
up that they're going to play their
schedule and they don't worry about the
other conferences Dan I don't think they
will and I know I know what the
reputation is I live down here but I
think the SEC would certainly like
somebody use a NASCAR Frazier like to
have a drafting partner they don't want
to be alone and I think I don't think
you you could see several conferences do
it and some not but I don't think you'll
only see the SEC play college football
this year the state of college football
right now feels like it's on hold but
what do you need to see before you think
we're going to have first of all games
and will we have fans in the stands
well I think to start I do not believe
that college football would be played
this fall unless there are stands fans
in the stands and most important and
students on campus and I know not to try
to make college football sacrosanct here
we all know what it is but I think the
people that run these universities
college presidents are not going to take
that type of hit they'll do almost
anything for money that's been proven
time and time again but but I think the
look would be so bad now spoken to
countless commissioners and athletic
directors and coaches and while there
may be a desire and a need to play to
stay afloat I don't believe the the
overwhelming majority of colleges will
play unless they can get students back
and I'm not talking about online and
that is why now that the draft has
passed and ultimately the Michael Jordan
documentary will move on as well I think
the biggest sports question moving into
the next four to six weeks is going to
be college football because it is a
mystery it's not like the NFL where you
can quarantine and get the players to
sign waivers it's it's real and I've had
parents and players call me on the air
and say I'm not letting my son play yeah
unless students are on campus I mean it
is a really intriguing conversation I
was told the pac-12 is in a little bit
of trouble from the standpoint of travel
and you know what's going on in
California the state of you know
California being quarantined but is is
the SEC probably in the best shape with
geographically you know this situation
yes and I think in the SEC I live in
North Carolina and my state my state its
Michael Jordan State it's one of the few
but not to get too deep into ideology
here but most southern governors have
followed the lead from from from the
president and have opened up and and I
think that makes it a little bit easier
but you know at the end of this
conversation they will have company the
ACC as we all know goes from Boston to
to Miami so I think you'll see a
majority of those those states go along
the big ten is more problematic I talked
to a reach up last night from the
University of Minnesota who doesn't
think we'll have college football who
doesn't take a lot of things so it's
it's a it's an amazing conversation and
and I bet I've asked this question since
March 12
five thousand times and add two
commissioners and I'm gonna like him and
I don't know remains the most common
answer yeah well I think you I we've
been setting these arbitrary dates and I
say it's dangerous because it gives
people this false sense of hope that
that's there or that it's like hey
everything will be good by then and
we're walking back these dates and if if
if the NFL comes but if the NFL plays
though Paul I wonder what that does to
college football and just putting
pressure on hey the NFL's plan why
aren't you guys well I think tomorrow
night is going to be interesting when
the NFL schedule comes out I think the
reality is going to seep into everyone
outside of the NFL that they're back
regardless they'll figure out a way to
get games in and I think the most
dangerous sign to college football is
the story that came out the other day
that the NFL without college football
will play on Saturday and ultimately on
Saturday night so that's a constant ball
has already been diminished because of
the NFL I bet you go back six seven
years ago not only the other Club at the
NBA six seven years ago
college football may have ranked number
two behind the NFL the explosion of the
NBA has pushed college football back
even more so they do not want to cede
that power but but here's the real issue
in college football Dan I know you're a
fan and you know what I'm about to say
nobody is in charge
this isn't like Roger Goodell can can
can put out an edict or Manford or
someone else there is not one person who
runs college football you have these
five commissioners and I liken them to
the good old days of the five families
who ran the mob in New York and they
zoom in every day we are and they have
these conversations and there's an ex
officio member who really does have a
vote match Jack Swarbrick of Notre Dame
and a few other occasional guests as
long as they bring good food and and
that's where we are right now and these
are all very independent and autonomous
thinking people but I do believe when
they say they want to find a cut some
common ground
you mentioned the pac-12 that that has
been the outlier in college
all for a long time they there that they
have been nowhere to be found
the at least other than I think twice
and the college football playoff so they
will not be the most important component
of this conversation it's Paul Finebaum
from the mothership you can hear him on
ESPN radio sirius XM channel 81 every
single day a couple other things this
conversation is starting to emerge now
about you know Trevor Lawrence and who's
going to tank for Trevor Lawrence like
you know the Dolphins were tanking for
two if Joe Burrell came out of nowhere
and had this wonderful wonderful season
may be the greatest season of all time
at that position if you were you know
investing in stocks and I said I gave
you two a Trevor or Jill burrow in the
NFL well gee invest in I would invest in
Trevor Lawrence and I we've already had
the conversations about the other two
but but I think he has the raw talent
when you look at Trevor Lawrence on a
football field in the ground level it's
astonishing to see and he did not have a
good year in 2019 I say that with his
team being undefeated and not only
losing one game I mean but he was off he
got a press way too hard in the
beginning I think he was born Dan I
swear he he looked at the defense's
especially in the HCC and said I've got
to challenge myself I'm gonna try to
find the narrowest window I can to
replicate what I'm gonna do at the next
level and he struggled at the gate he
found his rhythm later on but but I
think he's the best of those three but
Burrell is an enigma and and I still
think he'll have a good career I'm not
sure I think Joe Burrell will will be a
hall-of-famer
twoa is is either gonna be one of the
greatest or there's no there's no way of
getting around that one yeah the whole
Trevor Lawrence you know he's he can't
miss you keep hearing that can't miss
it's like Andrew Luck we see this
occasionally like once every generation
you have the quarterback Andrew Luck was
that John Elway was that I don't know if
we've had another one and then it looks
like it's gonna be Trevor Lawrence would
you say that he fits into that
Gouri in the expectations I do and I I
think don't forget he has a really good
cast around him and has had that at
Clemson but but there's just so much raw
ability there and I I will add one more
thing don't another you haven't but
Justin fields is someone to keep your
eye on as well i I realized that that's
not breaking news I think he's the
number two pick to win the Heisman but
two years ago he was in a backup
position at the University of Georgia so
I mean I wonder though about where we
all are as evaluators when you think
about the last three Heisman winners had
to leave where they were and they were
the number one draft choice as well
because they couldn't get a starting job
that's it not to crack on Urban Meyer
but I will I mean okay don't forget Cam
Newton went to play for Urban Meyer and
never saw a starting position and and
neither did Joe Burrell and they both
were the first place and the drought
that's your parting shot good to talk to
you Paul hope you're well thank you bye
that's Paul Finebaum